as you'll know by now a gunman entered a
school in texas and killed at least 18
children and two adults and while we can
add our prayers for the dead
there is nothing that can ever be said
that can approach the immeasurable grief
of those families it was a somber night
in late night television as stephen
colbert and james corden emotionally
addressed the mass shooting in uvalde
texas that left 19 kids and two adults
dead i just want to let you know shortly
before i came out here tonight we
learned of the unspeakable shooting in
uvalde texas today both hosts get
completely choked up stephen during his
monologue urging viewers to send their
prayers and while we connect our prayers
for the dead
there is nothing
that can ever be said that can approach
the immeasurable grief of those families
but while we're at it
let's pray this time our leaders show a
modicum of courage in trying to prevent
this from ever happening again
and hoping for change he gives a clear
and concise message
but prayers won't end this
voting might so when you vote ask
yourself this question who running for
office has publicly stated
that they're willing to do anything and
everything in their power to protect
your children from the criminally insane
number of guns in america meanwhile
james spends the entirety of his show's
opening monologue nearly in tears and
reveals the news broke just moments
after they finished filming the show
james apparent to three little ones says
the tragedy is unfathomable as a father
i can't imagine the horror of that phone
call
when i drop my kids off at school this
morning and kiss them goodbye it doesn't
cross your mind that that could ever be
the last goodbye
and the thought of that phone call
that your child is the victim in a mass
shooting is
beyond comprehension as a human being
then he shares his grief for the
families who suffer devastating losses
and slams america's backward gun laws
james says that despite america being on
the forefront of medicine of technology
of innovation there's work to be done
with gun control this year there have
been no school shootings in england this
year there have been no school shootings
in japan
this year there have been no school
shootings in australia this year there
have been 27 school shootings in america
and 212 mass shootings and we are just
five months into the year and james
admits he won't be surprised by more
tragedies if no action is taken so just
as i stood here in this studio last week
and i talked about a mass shooting at a
grocery store in buffalo today
heartbreakingly is in an elementary
school in texas and i'll probably be
stood here
talking again in another week or two
about another place i hold out hope
that this country will eventually wake
up and change this senseless gun culture
while my heart
simply goes out to every single person
in texas tonight
you